and now I'd like to present today's
speakers Victoria Wu PhD is a lecturer
at Stanford University and an
interpreter with more than 25 years of
experience in startups international
management and academia Victoria has
devoted the past decade to bridging
academia and business by Co designing
custom executive programs at INSEAD in
Harvard where she helped fortune 500
clients curates learning journeys for
six wheat leaders and high potential
managers in these roles Victoria has
also facilitated dialogue and
cooperation among worldwide business
partners alumni and clients since
returning from a decade working in Asia
Victoria has served as a mentor for
black box dot VC a nonprofit
organization serving the global
interpreter lock system and as an
advisor for early-stage startups
Victoria is now working on our sixth
startup which is focused on increasing
engagement in the sense of community
among hourly workers joining Victoria
today is Linda Smith a lecturer in
global entrepreneurial marketing at
Stanford University and a marketing and
sales executive with more than 25 years
of experience Linda has spent the last
15 years in high technology products and
services as the SVP of marketing or CMO
for a number of companies including
Genesis telecommunication laboratories
nuance Genpact and jive software in
these roles lead Linda has successfully
led virtually every marketing function
including product marketing products
management corporate marketing field
marketing lead generation channel
marketing marketing research and
strategy development all driving
marketing in the US Europe India China
and other major markets Linda has an
undergraduate degree in liberal arts
from Simpson College and an MBA from the
Wharton School of Business at the
University of Pennsylvania her current
area of interest is what is happening in
this next generation of marketing where
digital media and social networks are
combining to reshape the arts and
science of marketing professors the
floor is yours
good morning everyone just a little
something about what we do at MSN a 271
global entrepreneur marketing is
effectively what it is I start with
global then entrepreneurial then
marketing what we do is we need to use
the core marketing concept to bring a
new product or service to market but
also will help you build it to a success
we go towards both in entrepreneurs and
entrepreneurs
from the pool I saw that 45% of you had
said that you're starting your own
companies or running your own companies
so I think that would be a wonderful
what we call product market fit for you
for the course and what your needs are
the course is basically going to be a
team based and focused on delivering a
golden market strategy so without
further ado that need to choose Linda
yeah great to be with all of you and
very excited that you have interest in
the global entrepreneurial marketing
program I've been very excited to be a
part of this program now for over 15
years and what's exciting about it to me
is the fact that we help people who
perhaps have never had any formal
education or formal background in the
marketing area get all the basic
elements that they need to ultimately
create a go to market plan for their
company for their new product their new
offering as well as if they're in an
organization understand what's going on
with marketing in a way that they can
really contribute so what we're going to
be going through today is what makes
marketing in an enterpreneur knurl
environment different we will also be
diving into some marketing fundamentals
just so you have an idea of how to kind
of think about marketing and then
finally we'll do a high-level view of
what a go to market strategy actually
includes at one point they said can you
tell them everything you would tell them
that you know they would learn and in
the gem program it's like ah yeah I need
like 20 sessions to doing that is what
gem is all about so jumping in then just
little bit of background you heard my
bio seems it was just a little bit dated
but the last company that I was formerly
an up in an operational role she's
strategy officer chief marketing officer
was Twilio which was a platform
for developers which was an amazing
experience and now I am actively
advising and consulting for a number of
companies one that is especially fun is
mystique which is a robotics company
based on AI and some really deep
learning techniques so super fun and I
will bring that into the classroom so
you have an opportunity to learn a
little bit about what we're doing with
robotics at the same time as learning
what we're doing with entrepreneurial
marketing there let me turn it back over
to Vic for her to give you her
background perfect Thank You Linda
so my background basically are three
major buckets and starts with corporate
the corporate America so to speak and
academia and entrepreneurial ecosystem
what I bring to the table is just a both
success and failure and a number of
entrepreneurial ventures as mentioned
this is my sixth startup and I would say
there have been ups and down in each of
those I would imagine that the the most
I can bring the table that is when we
raise 17 million dollars and frankly I
think without product market fit it was
not actually a good thing
and also I bring to the table a lot of
mentorship that I've had a lot of
experience advising small and early
startups and understanding a global
perspective as I've lived in Asia for I
guess a lot of part of the decade and
without spending too much on you'll get
to know us throughout the quarter and if
you were to join our class but we will
go straight into the agenda as we
realize that time is short awesome buy
the other one other comment is one thing
you'll find with the classes it is very
interactive we love to have you be able
to engage with us that you you have an
opportunity to ask all the questions
that you have but also learn from each
other because we have a fair number of
people in the program that either have
experience having been in an
entrepreneurial or an entrepreneurial
organization or they're just starting to
get into one so lots of opportunity to
learn from your peers so let's jump to
the next slide and I thought it might be
useful to first just start off with what
is marketing because a lot of the people
that come into the gym program actually
have never
Marketing course or a marketing activity
before and so when you think about
marketing there's some wonderful
definitions out there when I first did
the Google search on these to crack me
up how many different ways marketing has
been defined this one from being a
consumer actually resonated with me
marketing is helping your customers
understand how much they need something
they never knew they need it which quite
frankly is how you sometimes feel as a
consumer but the one I really believe in
is the next one if you'll flip it over
Vic is this one that is much broader
marketing today is finally customer
focused social media made that happen
markets are once again conversations
marketing is about knowing the market
creating the right product to Vic's
point about product market fit
creating desire for that product and
then letting the right people know you
haven't what I think of marketing I
think of it as a very broad end-to-end
process which I'll touch on in a moment
but it is this idea of coming up with
right ideas and I'm really moving them
to market by having the right go to
market plan and again that's what we
want to make sure you leave with after
being a part of the gym program click
over to the next slide all right so
we've just talked about what marketing
is what does it mean to be
entrepreneurial marketing well the
reality is it is based on all the
fundamentals of traditional marketing
and we're going to give you a sampling
of that across the course but it is also
about this mindset that comes it's
defined by this orientation and if
you've ever been in an entrepreneurial
organization and as the poll showed
there's a fair number of you 45% that
are actually starting your own companies
there is this whole idea of it's about
moving fast you don't have time to stand
still it's about being agile being able
to pivot and constantly change what
you're doing from a marketing
perspective it's about leveraging the
passion that the organization has
because that's so much of what people
buy in the early days and it's also
about being creative which I'll touch on
in a moment now if you're someone
already in a formal organization and you
want to be a part of innovation what we
oftentimes call intrapreneurial all of
that applies as well even though the
organization may be older may
be more mature whenever you're bringing
that new idea that new concept to market
it goes back to all the principles of
being in that intrapreneurial
environment moving fast being agile the
lists we just covered it's also focused
on establishing a company in an industry
or a product in a segment and it's about
growing rapidly so all of those things
change the way you fundamentally think
about marketing because marketing very
traditionally has more of a planning
horizon to it we get comfortable with
longer windows of being able to define
campaigns of being able to put things
out into the market you can't do it when
you're in this entrant role mode now
there are challenges to that point of
being creative most entrepreneurial
ventures face unusual thing called no
one knows my company or my product or my
service usually you're in a very early
stage of product or service so you're
trying to make sure it does have that
product market fit and if not how do we
move forward and then a lot of times
your resources are very modest which
just comes back to again you're in that
very early stage you're not necessarily
earning revenue yet so you have to
figure out how to market in the most
creative way that you can alright very
quickly after that I in my journey as an
entrepreneur anyway I'm always short on
time things should have happened
yesterday and it's short on cash so this
is exactly what we're bringing to the
table yeah absolutely so I thought it'd
also be interesting to share with you I
get three questions very commonly if you
jump to the next slide I get three
questions from the entrepreneurial
organizations that I advise so that I
work with first one is when do I hire
for marketing the next one is well who
do I hire first win and then what level
do I hire a net so I thought it might be
interesting just to touch on that
briefly here before we get into the
marketing fundamentals let's start off
with when do I hire for marketing you
can switch to the next slide typically
people start investing in marketing when
the product is ready for that broader
use versus just that feedback loop which
is really important in the early days
but now you want to get the word out and
you want people to really start coming
to you and wanting to learn more
you hire for marketing when revenue is
now a or the key objective you have to
or building up numbers so in a network
but now really you're being looked at as
you know what is that key result that we
need to have well it's either more money
or it's more users of a platform but
it's when you need to really now
generate start generating mass and it's
also when that current staff you have
just can't cover the marketing effort
what I found in some wonderful new
startups is it just happens to be that
the founder had a little bit of
marketing or so when they hired a dead
marketing before and they're actually in
the earliest days able to to handle it
but now there will be a point where oh
wow yeah we need someone who's really
done this done this before let's start
looking at bringing in the staff next
question if you could switch over really
comes in then - who do I hire and this
is just my point of view but it's worked
for me generalists are golden in those
earliest days when you're hiring for
marketing finding someone that has
pretty broad experience that just
focused on one area can be super helpful
I also find that the marketing model
drives it we'll talk a little bit about
the marketing model in a moment but
sales driven revenue well then you want
someone who knows lead generation sales
enablement if it's marketing driven
revenue then you want someone who knows
brand and campaign orientation if it's
about a platform play
you want someone who typically knows
developers and if it's about growth
hacking that's the model you're
following in marketing then you want
someone who is uber smart on the online
and digital side of things hires someone
who can get from A to Z with a lot of
help you don't have time to train these
folks also find someone who doesn't need
an army reporting to them because we're
talking lean moving fast and then if you
have a technically steep product find
someone who's technically steep as a
marketer and then the last question
which is what level do I hire in at
culture matters avoid title creep too
early and then you enable it don't
enable your best early starters to be a
part of the company experience level
doesn't necessarily mean title and then
finally ensure and all happens some
people are just better at a beginning
company these are also some of the
topics we'll talk about during gem as
you're thinking about the team that you
need to form and Vic is amazing when it
comes to team building and understanding
organizational design we'll talk about
this as well as we go through the
program so you can be thinking about how
you might have to bring that marketing
team together for your business yes and
to that end I do believe that in both
research and my experience there will be
different teams at different stages of
an entrepreneur endeavor so therefore
keeping these things in mind that
experience is not actually equal title
is really important as your first
marketing CMO may not remain a CMO for a
much much larger company all right so I
do give you just a little bit of view of
how to think about intrapreneur all
marketing now we're gonna dive into just
a few marketing fundamentals and these
are fundamentals that we leverage across
the program the first one on the next
slide really comes back to this idea of
this end-to-end view of marketing it's
an e to e process now in a lot of
companies all they think about marketing
is that kind of fourth column over it's
all about it's just about demand
generation how do you get me leads how
do you get any more customers but in the
most effective companies that I've been
a part of or I've advised they take a
much broader view of marketing marketing
is about the strategy and planning which
you'll see come out as we talk about the
go-to-market plan you would put together
they do own product in some capacity if
they don't have product management
reporting in to them directly they're an
active participant in defining that
product or service demand generation is
naturally a part of it you have to have
that and then also now this idea of the
customer marketing making sure that you
have retention Boyd I can tell you in
startups one of the biggest challenges
that they have when they go for their
next funding round is what was your
retention rate so if you don't think
about that early on how do we take care
of our customers it's not going to
happen
Marketing plays a role across all of
these parts of the spectrum and we'll
show you through the various sessions
how you do that if you'll jump to the
note please Vic and then jump in the
next is adding to that is really
reducing the friction of how you get
your customer to interact with you and
to you know either is switching over or
staying with you over time is a constant
test of this iterative way of thinking
about how you market and what mark what
exact product is going to be
so resonates with the end-to-end view of
marketing yeah now we are going to talk
just a little bit about more of that
demand generation column because it is
so central to when you're an early
startup it's one it is one of the things
you invest in probably the earliest and
marketing the whole area of this demand
generation now I joke with a lot of our
students who come in from a very
technical background and I'll ask a
question the first day how many of you
you know believe in marketing what do
you think marketing is and I always get
the feedback oh it's that fluffy stuff
and it's my personal mission and every
every time we were on the gym program is
for people to leave with a great respect
for the marketing function because there
really is a science around it but part
of what you're doing in demand
generation that is a science is you're
moving people through what we call this
hierarchy of effects taking people from
being totally unaware of a product all
the way through to where there's an
action whether that's purchase or sign
up or whatever the right conversion is
and there are layers to building that
natural understanding getting them to
that purchase point they have to be
aware then you have to feed them with
enough knowledge that they they
understand who you are what you stand
for and you can get to that point where
they actually like you and then have a
preference over the competition and then
finally get the conviction that they
want to engage with you and there are
marketing tactics that we use at each
stage of this now some people will also
call this the funnel taking people from
awareness to consideration to action
that tends you hear that a lot within a
sales organization perspective so we'll
talk through the program as well about
how do you get people through this
hierarchy of effects and again in a
startup world big chance that out there
that no one knows who you are so you
need to really pay attention how do you
get people there this profession co
marketing is really a bit of psychology
ethnography data scientist
decision-making so it's a lot that's
encompassed into this thing called
marketing which is fascinating yeah and
that's a great tip for the next slide
one of the things that I actually did in
my education did have a lot of
psychology courses a lot of sociology
courses and one of the things that
you've really resonated that is when
you're thinking about marketing what
you're really trying to do is help
people form these percept
and so the way a perception is formed is
first it comes into this idea of a
sensory registry that's when you just
first been exposed you saw the billboard
you saw the ad but it doesn't stick I
mean there's just something back there
that is familiar if you see it again and
what we're doing with this marketing
process is strengthening that signal so
we can get into that short term memory
and if we as marketers have done our job
really well we get all the way into that
long term memory where the real value
comes because then you get word-of-mouth
someone comes up and says hey I'm
looking for X and a person goes oh yeah
there's this company out there I've
heard of they're awesome you should go
check them out so part of this marketing
effort is tapping into the psychology of
people getting into their minds and if
you turn to the next slide it is not an
easy thing to do the average human
attention span is only seven seconds and
that's one second less than a goldfish
so a marketers job it's that necessarily
an easy job yeah it's kind of like the
attention economy that we're all vying
for people's attention and as a new
product is a little bit hard to do
unless you do a really good job of
planning your marketing absolutely now
to try to help with that whole idea of
how do you get into the mind of someone
how do you work through that that stages
of sensory short-term long-term we use
the tactic that we call or a strategy we
call integrated marketing which is
really this idea that you have to use a
whole variety of tactics to be able to
do it and that's because we all learn
differently we all have different
attention spans for different types of
content different types of media so we
actually will spend three of the
sessions talking about demand creation
and getting you familiar enough with
each of the tactics that are out there
and they're many more than what you see
on these bubbles it's just a sampling of
them so that you can start thinking
about your own company about your own
work and your own target audience and
really starting to think about what's
gonna be most effective to get people
through that hierarchy and get into that
long-term memory
all right so we'll also walk through
this in the program there are different
types of marketing and these are kind of
the old traditional words for it if you
will
there's the idea of b2b marketing and
this is really about catering to
businesses here your target audience is
a business as well as the buyer that is
internal to that company so if you're
selling an enterprise software product
you know chances are you want to get to
the person who actually uses it but
probably also there's a cio that's
involved there's a CFO involved that you
have to include so multiple audiences
that you're catering to inside then you
have the world of b2c and this is really
about catering to consumers we all are
the recipient of that target audience
the consumer one we hear a lot about now
a lot of startups a lot of
entrepreneurial efforts going after it's
the idea of b2b to see here you're
catering to the businesses that cater to
consumers oftentimes you also have to
cater to the consumer so you get both
the push in the pull and your target
audience then tends to be the business
the buyer as an individual again and the
consumer and then the last one you're
seeing a lot more activity around in
terms of types of marketing is this idea
of B to D which is about catering to
developers here you're really focusing
on that individual developer to get them
excited about what you're doing and
there are different ways that you
approach marketing in each of these
types and so we'll be going through that
as well from figuring out what the right
product market fit is to how you're
creating that demand how do you create
great experiences for customer loyalty
well make sure it relates back to each
of these types of marketing and to it to
that end there are instances where you
may have multiple markets so your
customer may be in one of five different
customer types what we'll be using are
some cases they'll be underlying all the
different business models and illustrate
how other people have done it for
instance in in the past and some new
ways and novel ways of thinking about
being creative about marketing to so
many different constituencies yeah and
one of the things that both Vic and I
will work very hard is bringing in our
own experience as well so one of the
things I love about this program is
because I'm actually hands-on
practitioner even today I love sharing
what I'm doing getting your feedback on
it but trying to bring in those real
world examples as well from my own past
experience all right touching on that
idea of platforms so
when we talk about the B to D play with
developers generally what you'll find is
it does surround this idea of platform
place which is the fact that we've now
all realized that sometimes the greatest
source of innovation is outside the
walls of your own organization or
company we'll also be talking about
platform plays not only from the
perspective of developers but how you
build up a platform play so that you
know you've got the chicken and egg
thing you're trying to solve in terms of
ok for this platform to be effective I
need both of these types of audiences
how do I bring them both in so swoozie
spending some solid time on platform
plays which you see more and more
companies adopting all right going to
another another way to look at all of
this so I offered up the traditional
types of marketing b2b b2c through my
experience one of the other things that
I've realized is that Wow and I hate to
say it I'm dating myself this whole
thing called the internet changed my
world ecommerce changed my world and
what you start finding is because EECOM
is a vehicle for not only b2c but B to
be B the b2c that if a product is hard
to convey the value for what the price
tag is or it's hard to get up started
and buy started and running then you
have to have humans involved salespeople
involved it doesn't matter if you're b2b
or b2c you'll think about any phone plan
the reason why so many of the carriers
have pop-up stores have full fledged
stores is you go to their website and
trying to figure out what rollover
minutes mean and how many family members
can burn I mean there's so much
complication in a plan you have to talk
to human that's a b2c company but they
act a lot like a b2b organization in
fact and from the standpoint of having
sales so I look at that as a sales
driven revenue model regardless now on
the same token you know if it's easy to
buy and get started and it's easy to see
the value then you know chances are
you're gonna be selling it through an
econ alit can be largely marketing
driven revenue and again it doesn't
matter whether or not it's a consumer
player or a business play an old-time
example for me is Yammer they completely
disrupted the platform business the
social
business the platform business that job
was in by making it so easy to buy and
so easy to see the value but they were a
b2b place so when we think about those
traditional models they're always
important to come back to because so
much of the world thinks of it that way
but will also be tapping in and talking
about how is it that b2b and b2c
sometimes really overlap in the tactics
that you use next slide and
understanding whether you are fitting a
sales driven revenue model a marketing
driven revenue model this platform play
or growth hacking it all drives
marketing's role the focus the team that
you build the skills that you need and
the budgets that you have and I'm just
going to share one last super important
fundamental and this dates back if any
of you ever heard of the accom bust era
you'll recognize this little sock puppet
dude down there that was our biggest
problem we didn't follow this rule your
CAC cannot be greater than the lifetime
value of a customer it's just an out of
balance business model you'll never make
any money and CAC is that customer
acquisition cost and guess what
marketing plus sales we are that
customer acquisition cost what you want
to do is ensure that your lifetime value
is always greater than the amount you're
spending to acquire that customer so
we'll talk a lot about that as well and
how you make sure that you have a
balanced business model all the way from
top to bottom all right I'm gonna stop
I'm going to turn it over to you Vic now
to drive us home thank you
okay so next we're going to talk about
the global go to market strategy which
in our course is really the final piece
and we bring all the pieces that we will
the core marketing pieces that men
creation into a framework that is a
clear blueprint of actions so a golden
market strategy is defined as an action
plan that specifies how a company will
reach customers and achieve competitive
advantage the purpose of a GTM strategy
is to provide for blueprints for
delivering a product or service to the
end customer taking into account factors
such as pricing and distribution
in other words is really a program for
your customer to say hey I would like to
buy something from you and also the
experience and you would like for your
customer should have from the the click
that will get you the customer all the
way to the renewal process how easy is
it for that customer to get to you and
to help you generate the revenue that
you're needed and one of the things I'll
add on why we have put so much emphasis
on understanding how to create a go to
market plan in the program it's actually
twofold
you know first of all it is often the
first thing someone asks you you know
well what is your go-to market you know
strategy you know what's the plan that
you have and then kind of sit back and
go move that's again I better go figure
out what that is but the other thing is
I have actually worked in a number of
organizations now where the go to market
strategy was build it and they will come
and that can sometimes work for a short
period of time but then all of a sudden
when the numbers aren't there and people
are looking for where the numbers are
whether it's number of users or the
revenue you end up in a situation where
I was oh yeah yeah I guess I have to go
back now and create that strategy mm-hm
and we do measure what we do treasure
what we measure and a lot of
entrepreneur and marketing is about that
is the analytics and making decisions
based on the numbers that come back and
you if this particular way to sell a
product it does not work or this
particular way of pricing something
doesn't work we have to go back to the
planning to come up with the second
perhaps 2.0 of your go-to-market
strategy how a an organization will
benefit from gold market strategy is
both internal and external
it's a internal facing activity where
whether it is engineering R&D sales and
marketing all have to understand where
we're going with this thing
and it's also an external because you
have to include your customers into
thinking about how they would situate
your products as we are inundated with
so many products these days to put it
into a place where they can draw back to
perhaps long-term memory that will draw
out when perhaps they're looking for
that particular product or service
so some of the things that I like to
highlight is that it does have it helps
establish your path for growth it
maximizes your competitive opportunity
it's very iterative so it's not that we
just make one plan and go with it but we
will continue revisit the same plan so
that it will reduce your time to market
it reduces costs as we're all short of
time and money and it increases the
ability for us to adapt to change to
have a clear communication also
externally so some of the key questions
in the golden market would be well what
what is the market you want to pursue
what is your target audience who are the
customers you're going to be selling to
what are some of the personas how do
they behave what is their demographic
and what is your offering probably one
of the most important questions is how
would you create value for your
customers what are you selling and the
next question is what are the channels
that will get you to the customers we
looked at the various different ways and
different business models whether it's a
B to B B to B to C to D there are so
many different ways that we can
distribute this product these days we
have to think thoroughly about what
those channels may be in terms of sales
and distribution creating demand but
also as Linda had said if we cannot keep
a customer how do we provide customer
service to also be able to keep the
customers that we acquire and pricing is
a very big topic we're going to spend
one session on it probably not going to
be enough but pricing is how much you
would charge the customer how would you
maybe shifted based on the size of your
your your deal there are so many
questions and we we have to answer in
order for us to have a well-thought-out
go go to market strategy and last but
not least obviously how do you position
your market how do you position your
product in the marketplace what is your
unique value proposition how do you
differentiate from other products that
are very similar and potentially how do
you have maybe co-op addition we'll
spend a little bit of time in our
quarter to talk about that as well and
so if you take the global
entrepreneurial marketing program the
way we have structured the series of
lectures and topics is actually they
take you through everything that you
to answer all those questions that Vic
just went through if you decide not to
take the program well now you have the
questions you need to answer to create
your go-to-market Pro your go-to-market
approach so hopefully that will provide
some instant value for you
excellent you know the gold market
strategy is really a time and space
exercise when you first introduce the
product is going to have a certain set
of answers to the questions we just
posed in the growth phase obviously
that's very very important and when you
get to the maturity phase and then
perhaps you might want to pivot and as
your product declines into a phase where
you don't need as much marketing and you
may want to consider other products and
services to supplement as sales for
cents you can imagine they first were
going to be no software but now they
have totally embraced this platform
business they they go through the Trail
Blazers and Dreamforce activities that
they do now and of course they are
potentially two ways that you can look
at the various markets that you want to
market and for each of these you must
also answer all those questions that we
had just posed who is your target who
are your customers
what is that pricing going to be how
you're going to reach them and how you
gonna sustain them okay with that should
we open it up for questions then do you
have anything else to add yeah I just
say yo global like the global marketing
program I think is a super fun program
there's a lot of opportunity for you to
you'll really dig in and learn not only
from what we provide the presenters that
come in as well as your your fellow
students and you know if it's important
to you to have the right go to market
strategy again whether you're a brand
new startup or you're trying to bring
something new out from a more mature
company I think you're gonna learn what
you need from us wonderful thank you
both Victor and leader for this
fascinating brief and very fast overview
of so many interesting concepts I'd like
to open with questions coming from our
audience talking about the early days of
new ventures and specifically a question
came in from a participant who's
wondering how do you
convinced a highly technical founder CEO
weapons to have a PhD in electrical
engineering how do you convince an
individual like that coming from
hardcore scientific background to invest
in marketing how would you go about
doing that yeah yeah I can definitely
jump in on that one
been there done that multiple times now
so there are a number of ways that it
happens first of all you know if you're
already very in the company and you're
trying to convince them it's now time
because of the way that technical
founder is thinking you know you have to
bring facts to them you have to you know
build a case if you will that shows the
why behind it and working with engineers
and developers that's one of the key
things I always do is I always to try to
answer the why behind we need to do it
why we need to do it so part of it is
building up that that case for why it's
important now at this juncture in the
company it's also about earning their
trust though and you know as I said you
know one of my goals in the program is
get over the the perception people have
of marketing's just fluff and it's a
waste of time so that they really
understand how it can benefit that
business and earning that trust with the
technical founder is super important you
know that you understand the product
that you understand the market that
you've talked to the customers and so
what you're really representing is
something that he can trust or she can
trust I should say as well I'll tell you
it the other way it happens very
honestly is if it's a company that's
already gone out and it's got angel
investors series a maybe sometimes even
a sighted series B the VCS will
definitely push on that and there will
be a point where they say you need to
get someone in here who knows marketing
and what will oftentimes drive that is
that the numbers aren't making it the
projections aren't there and they
realize that the product itself is not
just going to bring the people in so
there's the do it internally build the
trust answer the why or it will come
from the outside to that and also the in
my experience and technical co-founders
often at
we can appeal them through logic and
basically if you have a lot of customer
stories that can help illustrate the
point of we do need to do marketing and
you know I've had a lot of investors
breathing down my neck and frankly I was
not a technical founder or co-founder
but we did realize very quickly we had
to bring somebody in for marketing
because the metrics just didn't show
that we were growing or we're not
selling the product in the way that we
had planned for it does that answer your
questions thank you my question is about
social media and specifically with
social media being so prevalent in
today's world does it make sense to
launch marketing activities on social
media before the product or service is
ready to launch and if so would you also
do it in an organic fashion or a paid
fashion and perhaps you can talk about
when do you start investing in social
media okay maybe I'll take a stab at it
first in a lot of my startups I
basically would allocate a very small
amount of money just to do product
validation validation does anybody want
this thing beyond my group of friends so
to speak and once you establish a little
bit of that I think with social media it
is a it's not a very costly way to just
get earlier validation of your products
and services and at which point maybe
you can be quite smart about collecting
data for instance you may start offering
this product or service to a certain
group and watch those metrics and maybe
open it up for discussion and say hey
you guys are the early users what would
you change about this what do you love
about this and what do you hate about
this so I do think think that marketing
would not be marketing without social
media or any kind of social platform
Linda yeah I think you know what I would
add to that is my first response to the
individual would be well who is your
target audience because in my experience
social media is different roles to play
for a company it will always be there
but there's some audiences that you just
can't reach through social media it's
not where they live it's not where they
get their their information
so using social media for that you know
type of a target audience it's just not
going to be effective there are other
audiences with where it's like yeah that
is where they hang out and you get down
to the particular social media vehicle
be it a Facebook or you know twitch TV
or you figure out you know what the
right vehicles are the other thing in
this kind of plays off what Vic was
saying you also in a social media
strategy need to define what your
objectives are and what Vic was really
talking about is you know figuring out
from almost that kind of market research
perspective of do you have that right
product market fit are you getting the
right features into the product you may
find that social if they if that's not
where they live from a perspective of
learning and demand creation that social
for you is a channel for customer
support and that's really where it sits
so you know when I look at a start-up
and do you use social or not first thing
I do is go back to who's the target
audience and is this where they live in
terms of getting information being
persuaded to move through that hierarchy
of effects then I sit back and say okay
what do we really want to accomplish
with social which could be market
validation or it could be customer
support or it could be that demand
creation then I go out and figure out
what are the right tactics thank you the
next question has to do with moving from
the early days to take the growth phase
and we mentioned earlier the generalists
are golden in the early days when do you
know the time to start hiring for
technical expertise in marketing yeah so
you know first of all one of the the
immediate signals that I see in a
company that it is time to bring on
marketing is the fact that you know
they're looking at what the next growth
numbers are gonna be and they do an
internal assessment and they realize
okay you know it's either gonna take
more bandwidth than when we've been able
to put forward to it because we've had a
person doing that plus they're their day
job or they realize that they don't have
the specific expertise in the area of
marketing they need let's take an
example if a company is going to drive
heavy ecommerce interaction if
that is their the model that they've
picked chances are they're gonna need
someone that's heavy into digital heavy
into analytics and if they look around
the room and they don't have that then
that's gonna tell them you know it's
time to hire the other thing you know
that I would say is in terms of
technical and you can look at technical
different ways one of the mistakes that
I do see companies make is that they
will be a technical product and they
don't hire a technical resource within
marketing and by that I mean I just
helped a company that I advise put in
their CMO at it is a product that's
being sold to engineers as particularly
in the QA space and we needed to have
someone that came from that background
to actually be able to do the marketing
effort so the the gentleman has stepped
in and you know engineering background
has had to run QA before has a bent
wanted to do marketing so it's whole
career has been in marketing but he
comes with that level of technical
expertise oh just exactly what Linda
said plus a little bit more that I'd
like to add is that when a marketing is
not just something that happens it's not
an activity that needs to be looked at
on a contingency basis meaning that
maybe once a week we look at metrics -
hey we've got to be looking at metrics
every hour that's what you really need
to bring in a professional to manage
that and to make sense of what's really
happening excellent
and that cues the next question
regarding metrics and data and in the
LTV versus the customer acquisition cost
how do you define how do you make sure
to do the rights you do the definition
and the measuring of the customer
acquisition cost in the early days when
data is not readily available right how
do you how do you guide the management
team as you come in with a
recommendation where it'd be a certain
dollar amount or a percentage budget how
do you deal with those questions yeah
it's never that it's never easy the
reality is in the earliest days you are
dealing with that lack of data so there
are different ways that you can approach
it first of all you can look to see if
there are companies that are similar to
yours or selling in the same product
category and what has the traditional
CAC
for them traditional lifetime value been
for them an example was I was working
with a company that was in a high-end
electronics product space and we were
able to go out and just research online
you know what the average CAC was for
selling a high-end electronics product
via the econ channel though so there is
that kind of data out there that you can
tap into in the early days also you can
do a bottoms-up approach which is look
at all the vehicles that you want to use
and what the rough price of that would
be and that will start giving you an
idea of what the cost of acquisition
would be from the pure marketing
perspective if that sales driven revenue
then you also would bring in what is the
cost of having a that sales team on
board is that one person two people and
so you can do some bottom-up
calculations in the early days as well
in the early days is kind of like art
and science it's a lot of art and
creativeness that gives you some signals
some things I have worked for me
personally is going into communities and
talk to other founders in your own space
and they can give you some guidance it's
not science but it is some guidance
excellent thank you another set of
questions are coming regarding
innovation in marketing and I wonder if
from your a very strategic perch you can
share with us some of the innovative
approaches to marketing that you've
recently see and how would that be
how do people know to identify this
these next innovations in marketing that
can often give companies their
competitive advantage as I compete
against their peer competitors right
well I think that the biggest thrust
that I've seen as of late in marketing
that's kind of the next wave is
everything around analytics and there
you know a lot of companies now that are
leveraging AI and deep learning because
they've got the data around their
customers and I know AI as a way
overused term and has so many different
meanings out there today
it's really this idea of leveraging all
the data you have around you that can
give you a huge competitive advantage
over someone else if you learn how to
harness that data and put it to work
yeah I'd like to bring that also home to
the fact that we are marketing as a
multi discipline approach to being both
behavioral scientist to psychology so
your customers will be human beings so
that that data will help inform but at
the end of their designing these
experiences will potentially help you
get a competitive edge thank you perhaps
tension between product management
product marketing and marketing are
there tensions built-in between
marketing team and product marketing
product management who they go to
marketing is the product management is
it product marketing how do the various
individuals in these roles um I'll take
a stab at this it's a very complex
question and it's different with every
stage of an organization you know in in
the early stages that we dis there would
not be distinct you know product
management to program management to
other aspects of the team but as you
grow again I'd truly believe that a
go-to-market strategy is a plan that's
internally facing and externally facing
and everyone pretty much has to own a
piece if not all of it being cognizant
that what I do today will affect what
you do tomorrow Linda yeah I think it
has a lot to do also with the players
that you've hired in the company where
you have a strong leader in marketing
the CMO the VP of Marketing wherever
that the title level is if they believe
in this construct of marketing is an
end-to-end process they're going to step
in and take it over and on the go-to
market because they get how that is
directly tied to what they do at every
stage so I think that strength of
leadership in the marketing area drives
a lot of that if that
marking leader that you've hired is more
of a demand creation person that's
really where their sweet spot is that's
what they wake up and love to do then
chances are it'll be someone else in the
organization maybe they had a product
management that takes on that umbrella
of I want to own the go-to-market
sometimes even the the CEO or the
founder you know in a young company in
terms of that friction mode which is
kind of a second question under the
question about between product
management and product marketing what I
have found is that you know if product
management and product marketing can
really form a team relationship which
they need to then you can get away you
can get away from there being any
problems between the two organizations
if there is a dynamic where product
management feels that you know they're
kind of uber important because they're
driving how a product is built and
they're working with engineering and
that product marketing is just kind of
this afterthoughts the fluffy part then
you're gonna have problems and so again
you have that opportunity through
organizational design to make sure you
avoid that problem and also in MSME
we've seen a lot of students who go into
marketing and with that analytics
background it's um it's quite useful for
them to have the same language moving
forward I would like to wrap up by
asking both of you to talk about these
as you look at it your experience
teaching units before and teaching here
at Stanford in general and what should
you expect to get out of it of course we
covered all the material is how do we I
believe the people who get the most out
of this course are really people have
had very little exposure to marketing if
you have had a role in marketing or
you've taken marketing courses in the
GSB or a business school this would be
there you have incremental knowledge
versus a oh my gosh all these aha
moments yeah and to trim off of that I
get very excited by the students that
we've had in the program in the past
that are are now in companies and you
know they'll come back and say wow you
know I learned
so much during that program I've been
able to actually really apply it and had
I not gone to that proton through gym I
never would have had really any exposure
to marketing those are the ones that
seem to come out and are most excited
about what they learned if you've had
one marketing class I think we can
definitely build on it but to Vicks
point if you're someone who already has
a marketing degree or you've been
working you know 15 years in the field
we probably can't go deep enough in any
of the topics to give you what you're
really looking for fantastic questions
by the way I've been watching them
rolling in and it's been very hard not
to jump in and answer those actually
right here by text yes thank you all
right
you